marcus in tokyo got a boost from this
morning's news that japanese prime
minister yoshihide suga will step down
paving the way for a new head of
government to lead the world's third
largest economy japan's main stock index
the nikkei rose nearly two percent after
the announcement the news came as a
surprise but has investors optimistic
with analysts saying the market welcomes
the possibility of former foreign
minister fumio kishida succeeding suga
just yesterday kashida gave a talk about
the economic policies he would implement
if he were chosen as prime minister
among these were a stimulus package to
assist companies and households
suffering under recent restrictions
we will swiftly pass a sufficient
economic stimulus package worth tens of
trillions of yen for people who have
faced disadvantages from government
policy and for those who are in trouble
due to covet
for the time being
many countries are continuing to show
aggressive stance in fiscal monetary
policy and monetary easing
so i think our country must not fall
behind from this
all right for more let's cross over to
tokyo and journalist michael penn
michael good to have you on the program
so the nikkei up two percent um our
market is excited about fumio kishida or
excited about somebody else that is not
the current prime minister
it would seem that what the markets is
specifically are reacting to is the
sense that uh
kishida or if somebody else uh becomes
prime minister uh you know kishida might
be the leading candidate but he's by no
means a shoe-in uh that that prime
minister will most likely have a large
stimulus uh
package as part of their early part of
their administration so i think that's
what the markets are most likely
reacting to is the idea that the
government is about to spend a lot more
money no matter who uh becomes the next
prime minister all right but japanese
japan is already heavily indebted
is another stimulus package most likely
financed by debt
really what the country needs
uh yes well as you say the the japan has
a real structural problem with debt uh
in fact among advanced economies it's
it's you know proportionally the most
indebted in the world uh this is not a
new situation
um
well uh i think that uh
despite this this sort of long-term
problem uh japan nevertheless uh
probably well it will welcome the
stimulus whether it needs or not i
suppose would depend on the economist
you consult with but uh i think that uh
because of the suffering which has uh
certainly uh you know spread around the
country due to the covid
factor uh it will be welcomed by the
public as well as by markets
michael penn in tokyo thank you
thank you